look at all of you it's I mean it's a
look at John and Honsou what a diverse
group of people am a amazing you know
Adriana Barraza Rinko Kikuchi Steve
Carell such diverse people here
I do I mean really think about that what
a wonderful night such diversity in the
room in a year when there's been so many
negative things that about people's race
religion and sexual orientation and I
want to put this out there if there
weren't blacks Jews and gays there would
be no Oscars
or for anyone named Oscar when you think
about that
so I say tonight we're gonna celebrate
you because you're nominated just
because you're nominated we're gonna
celebrate you I wish there was a way for
me to convey how much I want to
celebrate you a tambourine in my hand
what's this
Oh
Oh
oh boy well
I would not want to follow that our
first two presenters are Academy Award
winner Nicole Kidman and James Bond
himself Daniel Craig
good evening the first Oscar tonight is
for our direction the art director and
set decorators are asked to create an
entire world to which the audience can
run away to for a few hours this year
the nominated films took place in the
fantasy worlds of Pirates of the
Caribbean and Pan's Labyrinth in the
secret world of the magician in the
prestige and in the Good Shepherd and
dreamed wells the mutually exclusive
worlds of white America and black
America in the 50s and the 60s we were
there thanks to the extraordinary work
of these nominees for best art direction
John Mayer for the art direction and
Nancy Hague for the set decoration of
dream girls Jeannine off a wall for the
art direction and Gretchen rau and
Leslie Rollins for the set decoration of
the Good Shepherd a haenyeo Caballero
for the art direction of Pilar a welter
for the set decoration of Pan's
Labyrinth
Rick Heinrichs for the art direction and
Cheryl kurasov for the set decoration of
Pirates of the Caribbean Dead Man's
Chest nathan crowley for the art
direction and Giulio to pin t for the
set decoration of the prestige
yeah and the winner is Pan's Labyrinth
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Johanna Caballero and
Pilar is welcome
well the first one of the night just
some quick thank you so we want to thank
first of all today Academy for this
dream come true it's an honor for us
thank you to our crew they made a
wonderful job no to picture house to all
of our producers they've been
tremendously supportive em to Guillermo
Navarro for his beautiful light to
Guillermo del Toro for guiding us
through this lever and now and I want to
thank my wife and my family for for the
support and I want to dedicate this to
the memory of my mother
and all the filmmakers of my country